رغم الهدوء هنا الا ان مخيم بعلوله في
البقاع الغربي كان ساحه من ساحات
المداهمات التي شنها الجيش اللبناني على
اللاجئين السوريين قبل ايام
المداهمات ليست جديده لكنها المره الاولى
التي يسلم فيها لاجئون الى القوات السوريه
داخل سوريا يعني بحب انه الامم بتوقف يعني
تتصل فينا تتواصل معنا تعطينا يعني افادات
عشان نقدر نجدد ما نعيش بخوف يعني هدول
اللي اخذوهم واحد كاسر شهرين وواحد ثلاثه
اشهر واحد عمره خمسين سنه من المخيم يعني
اخذوا لانه كاسر مداهمات الجيش اللبناني
تزامنت مع حمله كراهيه متبادله على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي حملت اللاجئين مسؤوليه
الانهيار الاقتصادي لكن على ارض الواقع
بدل مشهد مختلفا لان العمال قديما مش من
اليوم وازمتنا مش من وراهم
يمكن هن عم يشتغلوا وعم يفيدوا البلد وعم
في منهم ما بيطلع في منهم
قيمته وبيحمل حاله وبفل
كل شخص اليوم ما بيحمل ورقه معينه ما عنده
اوراق شرعيه بتوقف وبينحجز زيت السرقه
خاصه بهيدا الوضع كان بطاريه السياره
الانترنت قديش كله صار فيه خلافته شوي
بينما اتخذت بلديه وذوق مصبح اجراءات
لتنظيم وجود اللاجئين بالتعاون مع الجيش
والقوى الامنيه انتقد رئيس اتحاد بلديات
السهل في البقاع المداهمات العشوائيه هلا
رح نعمل بيانات بالعمال الموجودين
بالبلديه عم يشتغلوا شغل ما بيقدر يشتغلوا
اللبناني وانا دعيت المصانع
والمعامل الموجوده
انه يناقضوا امورهم عبر هاي الناس ويسووا
لهم وضعهم واللي فيه يعمل له كفاله يعمل
له كفيله يضل يشتغل لانه وقف الشغل ثلاث
أربع ايام عندي بغزه هون منذ بدء ازمه
اللجوء اطلق المجتمع الدولي خطه الاستجابه
للازمه في لبنان بدعم من الامم المتحده
تهدف الى تقديم المساعدات للبنانيين كما
السوريين حاولنا التواصل مع وزاره الشؤون
الاجتماعيه لكن وزيرها هيكتور حجار رفض
اعطائه اي تعليق غنوه يتيم العربيه البقاع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات